jessica keynote speaker we're here
create and cultivate if people take away
one message
from what you have to say today what do
you hope that is
i really want people to understand
who they are and what they want um
i keep saying that it sh don't let it be
about money money will come
you know like nurture your idea
you everyone here is so unique with all
of their ideas it's like
a room full of it's just amazing it's
like a room full of like cloud with the
thinking cloud you know
and everybody is so inspired and
like ready and i love that readiness in
people
and i feel like if you always have that
readiness
your brand will always grow and there's
there's never
you know you're just unstoppable i do
want to take you down memory lane
because
20 years ago right the year 2000
you brittany christina you guys are at
the top of the trl charts
and now you are here talking about a
billion dollar business
are you kind of surprised where each of
your careers
have taken you no i think everybody's
careers have their own unique stories
you know
and i i love it that britney owns
herself christina owns herself
and they don't let the world control
them they just
are themselves and that's who i am as
well and
we grew up in a very competitive um
environment when it came to like our
record labels and
being pushed to do things that were
unnecessary
for success and to know that
you know everybody has found their own
way in such
um in such a beautiful like inspiring
way like
i just love it that everybody has
remained authentically to who they are
well in the book you kind of talk about
that right and there is enough room at
the top for any butt for everybody
there's so much room at the top i mean
think about how many people are in
heaven come on
there's there's a lot of room at the top
and
and i am happy to share any top slot
with anybody but
the fact that like i'm even considered
at the top is like a very funny thing
like but but because i always i always
i'm a dreamer so i have
more things to do so this is it's never
i'm i'm very happy
but i am not standing still
what else is on that list like what does
the jessica empire look like
five years from now five years from now
i mean we
we just launched jessica simpson.com
like we've been doing
the entire brand without e-commerce so
now that we have e-commerce it's been so
fun to navigate
and to see exactly what people are
buying
from where what size what's working
and then be able to deliver that because
we basically are like we buy our own
stuff and
sell it through that and it's just been
it's been a really
fun thing and then i get to like do some
blogs on it and like really make it the
world of
of me and i think people can really
relate to it
and so it's exciting to do the dot com
but
i look forward to hopefully having
stores i want to do a lot in like
health and wellness for sure that's
something that i haven't done yet
the goop route or i mean i love goop i
absolutely
completely respect goop but i try and
make our stuff as
my customer is kind of different because
they come to me
and they want something that they can
afford and have all your shoes girl
and and for me like i'm not
you know i i will help others for sure
like
with their brands and that type of thing
but i always want to keep it
at a good price point for middle america
could you ever do a vegas residency is
that on the bucket list
that is not on the bucket list but
um i mean i don't
i don't know i feel like i have to write
a lot more songs to have a vegas
residency
your catalog is good though yeah no i
have i have a good catalog
but i mean that's i mean i would do
broadway before i would do vegas
you would do broadway though you have
broadway dreams
of course i'm like a power ballad singer
i like to move people and give them
chills and take them through the emotion
of the story yeah would it be a broadway
show about your life or is there a role
in mind you just never know
right now a lot of things are happening
a lot of things are happening book has
opened a lot of doors talk about the
book because it's amazing
it's inspiring do you kind of ever take
like a step back and look at what your
story is doing
and how like your impact and how you're
helping people of course i mean i
daily reflect and
think about all these people that have
been meeting at these in stores
and like people have been reading this
book within two days
you know i'm like wait you already read
it it just came out you know to put down
yeah i love it that it's a page turner
but i also love it
that so many people can relate to it in
different ways
and so it's really made me have a lot of
confidence in the power of my voice you
know
like i know i have a powerful singing
voice but to have a
powerful voice that is filled with hope
and faith
and inspiring others to be their best
self
is and and to face their fears because
truly like fears can absolutely
tear us apart and i don't think we need
to give
power to that fear and at the moment we
give power to that fear
we let it defeat us and we're all
stronger than that fear and being on the
other side of fear
i can tell you that very confidently
it's a good place to be
i love that um ashley congratulated you
yeah on the book
did your parents what did they think of
the book they were reading the book the
entire time
yeah i was sending them chapters and
chapters and
um it really connected us in so many
ways because
i mean for me a lot of the stuff that i
wrote about
were stuff that was in my journal so i
was going back to my 15 year old self
or to my 20 year old self and i was
really like nurturing that
girl who was trying to grow up and
trying to understand her life and trying
to understand perspective
and the power of that and i really feel
like with my family like we connected
so much and we're stronger because of it
it was almost like doing family therapy
or something
so what did mom and dad say after they
they read it was there anything they
were maybe like
wary of no i mean they didn't take out
anything they
they said this is your story it has
wings
you've always had a light within you and
it's time to shine i mean they
definitely
have said that to me since i was a
little kid so
that has never changed did the book
inspire any of them to maybe want to
write a memoir
i mean i'm trying to convince ashley to
write a memoir she has a lot of good
stories
before i let you go i want to talk about
your hubby and how he's been supporting
you through all of this
unreal it's unreal i mean through this
i mean the pride that he takes
in our love and in me as a woman
is so sexy and it is so empowering
because
it he just knows that this is my calling
and he knows that this is
my path and he's just there to hold my
hand through it and
he's really like the backbone to who
i am because like any time i feel like i
can't stand
i mean he's there to hold me up and
tell me that i actually can seriously i
mean how do you guys balance things you
have the kids you have the business the
empire
what is your guys's secret after five
years
our secret after five years well i know
what will may 21st will be our 10-year
anniversary
yeah you've actually been together yeah
wow yeah i count the first day that we
met because it was pretty instant
and it was definitely instant yeah i
think he like moved
in a month later so we knew
you know when you know you know
especially like
both of us we had been through the
divorce we had
other relationships we knew exactly what
we wanted in a person
in a companion and exactly who he wanted
to raise children with
and we were that for each other and
through
all of this like we've only become
stronger i mean
the moment i said i was going to stop
drinking he gave it up too
and right when you did so you the same
day so
he was just like okay i'll do this with
you you know it's like not even like an
ass he didn't like second guess it or
think about it
we haven't even talked about like it's
just one of those things like we both
made the decision
and haven't gone back you're happy yeah
i'm very happy i'm very content